if you've smelled popcorn you've smelled
the strange scent of a binturong also
known as a Bearcat
it roams the treetops in Southeast Asian
rainforest excreting the very same
compound that gives popcorn its smell it
does this to mark its territory and to
communicate with potential mates who I
guess love popcorn the binturong doesn't
leap from tree to tree like a monkey
instead opting to climb up and down but
it does have a prehensile tail in fact
it's one of only two critters in the
order Carnivora that be dogs and cats
and bears but not monkeys are people
that has one the other is the equally
odd kinkajou shown here shooting an
apple commercial apparently anyway in
addition to the prehensile tail the
binturongs ankles rotate 180 degrees to
help it scale trees this is a nocturnal
hunter but it's really more of an
omnivore it eats its fruits and veggies
like its mommy told it to and that means
it has a pivotal ecological role in the
rain forest the wind doesn't blow strong
enough here to disperse seeds widely but
that's where the binturong comes in it
eats the fruits and does its business
depositing the seeds far and wide and if
that's been Terron I don't want to be
bent alright